bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour un
deuxième épisode de la chronique la
modernité késako dans une première vidéo
on avait envisagé la question de la
modernité à partir de l'alimentation en
prenant comme exemple le cas du pain
aujourd'hui je vous propose d'examiner
la question de la modernité à travers
notre façon de se loger en prenant comme
exemple la maison alors pourquoi la
maison et bien des maisons il y en a de
toutes sortes la plupart sont en béton
en briques en pierre en paille en terre
ou en bois la façon dont on construit
est très révélatrice de ce qu'on
considère comme moderne en effet la
maison évoque l'intimité l'aspect
familial et aussi la façon dont une
société s'organise et tout cela est bien
sacré une quantité de stéréotypes
par exemple si je vous dis hommes
préhistoriques et maison vous pensez
cavernes et c'est pas faux mais ce n'est
qu'une toute petite partie de l'habitat
préhistorique et dans le même temps si
vous pensez maison contemporaine vous
allez certainement voir portail
électrique s'est enroulé en béton des
vitres et même si ce modèle de maison
n'est pas à votre goût c'est quand même
celui qu'on me propose dans cl c'est
minecraft donc ça nous donne quand même
une idée de la représentation que l'on
se fait de nos maisons
aujourd'hui très concrètement on va
étudier des maisons de différents types
et datant de différentes époques à
savoir la préhistoire et premières
habitations des hommes de cro magnon
puis au xxème siècle particulièrement la
période d'après-guerre où l'
architecture moderne fonctionnaliste
fait son apparition et on finira par le
cas des maisons construites aujourd'hui
dans les descriptions vous allez voir je
vais employer souvent les termes de
niveaux techniques par type
l'architecturé également la notion de
temps autant de facteurs qui sont très
important lorsque l'on construit est-ce
qu'on pourrait envisager d'appliquer ces
termes pour des constructions datant de
la préhistoire
ouais ça l'art mal parti pour l'instant
et pourtant les hommes préhistoriques ne
manquait pas d'idées parfois assez
génial pour bâtir leur maison
le premier exemple qui m'a frappé
lorsque j'ai fait mes recherches pour
cette vidéo c'est l'exemple des huttes
en os de mammouth en ukraine ces luttes
furent construites il ya quinze mille
ans
donc on est au paléolithique par des
groupes de chasseurs cueilleurs sur le
site de médéric en ukraine
on estime qu'une communauté d'environ 50
personnes y construisit 15 buts
comment procèdent art il dispose r
d'abord une série de crâne en arc de
cercle qui formaient la base du mur
intérieur il superposait ensuite 95
mandibules de mammouth le menton vers le
bas à chaque du toit était probablement
en bois et recouverte de peau cu était
assez grande pour être équipée d'un
foyer et accueillir des heures de
travail où les chasseurs confectionner
leurs outils et ustensiles en os et en
pierres entre les huttes
les habitants avaient aménagé des fosses
pour stocker leur nourriture
ce qui est intéressant et original c'est
que les modèles diffèrent d'une hutte à
l'autre tout en conservant une
architecture sophistiquée de telles
constructions un pic que ces sociétés
savaient organisé et dirigé des travaux
de construction
donc il ya là l'apparition d'une
certaine hiérarchie cela sous-entend
qu'il savait également régler des
conflits internes
en effet des populations réellement
nomades résolve bien souvent leurs
problèmes en se séparant en revanche des
peuples sédentaires sont obligés de
trouver des solutions et donc de créer
des institutions ou des bâtiments pour
maintenir la paix l'exemple de ces
huttes concentre toutes ces notions de
vie communautaire d'organisation
d'habitation et d'apparition des statuts
sociaux et cela à une pub très ancien il
y a quinze mille ans mais au fait
pourquoi du mammouth et bien parce que
c'est la ressource du coin tout
simplement les mecs à l'époque n'allait
pas s'embêter à faire des kilomètres
pour aller chercher du bois il prenait
les ressources locales ce qu'ils avaient
à disposition en l'occurrence en ukraine
du mammouth
cette tendance a va se vérifier sur
d'autres sites archéologiques on va voir
par la suite
mais avant d'aller plus loin précisons
un point essentiel lorsqu'on parle
habitat en archéologie et préhistoire on
pense évidemment à la caverne
on a tous l'image de l'homme de cro
magnon accroupis devant son feu dans une
grotte mal vêtues souvent torse nu elle
sort pourquoi avec une espérance de vie
assez faible et mec
j'ai quand même attrapé l'accre aide
alors pourquoi cette image là répond ça
serait trop longue a expliqué ici ça
fera d'ailleurs l'objet d'une prochaine
vidéo pour l'instant je vous propose de
laisser ce mythe avant et de se pencher
sur un site archéologique et fouillé
depuis des dizaines d'années et qui a
pas mal fait bouger les choses sur ces
questions c'est le site de pincement en
seine et marne
il y à treize mille ans des chasseurs
magdaléniens avait coutume d'y séjourner
durant l'automne ce campement
magdalénien fut découvert en 1964 il est
situé en bord de seine après la
confiance avec l'yonne c'est d'ailleurs
un endroit stratégique auquel les hommes
préhistoriques avaient songé
on venait chasser leur haine alors en
route vers les pâturages d'hiver et ce
type de chasse est très bien attesté
ethnographique mans notamment en sibérie
et ça on en parlera un peu après que
faisait tout un pincement et bien comme
je vous ai dit et des chasseurs qui
venait chasser leurs haines et ils
établissent c'est un campement dans ce
campement tout mais véritablement tout
tournait autour du renne tout venant du
rennes était utilisée est recyclé ont
fabriqué des sagaies et des outils en
bois de renne le traitement des peaux
était également fait à partir des outils
obtenu à partir des bois de rennes où
manger du renne on dormait sur dur n
maison était faite de rennes bon allez
programme de la journée qui fait quoi
toi là-bas web et toi rennes web comme
pour l'exemple des huttes en ukraine en
os de mammouth est bien ici c'est le
même procédé
on utilise qu'on trouve sur place alors
comment ces hommes s'organisent et il
est d'un plutôt bien à vrai dire le
campement est très bien foutu au centre
du campement sont implantés les ateliers
de taille de silex pour hommes femmes
enfants à proximité de chaque poste un
accès au feu pour le confort des
tailleurs des tapis peaux de rennes sont
placés au sol
on n'a pas oublié les zones de tri
sélectif déjà à l'époque les habitations
familiales sont placés non loin de la
zone de travail pour plus de proximité
et afin de limiter les temps de trajet
il ya même un atelier destiné aux leçons
de taille pour les plus jeunes
sorte de garderie préhistorique
s'immoler ce qui est assez nota po
pesant c'est qu'en un temps très court
les hommes sont capables de bâtir leur
campement de l'aménager et de créer des
zones de travail séparé des lieux de vie
il y a deux
des ateliers pour les hommes des
ateliers pour les femmes et des ateliers
pour les plus jeunes donc on retrouve
encore cette idée de hiérarchisation
entre les rôles les âges et sexes
impressionnant non alors évidemment
comment on arrive à de telles hypothèses
à partir de quelques restes de vestiges
et bien comme je vous l'avais dit avant
ces l'ethnographie qui nous apporte
beaucoup de précision puisqu'elle
démontre qu au kamtchatka en sibérie en
2001 les populations nomades vivant du
renne s'organise de la sorte une autre
expédition en 1987 dans la péninsule
taimyr a étudié l'architecturé détente
tchoum où la couverture est surmonté de
peaux de rennes comme à pinces vent on
n'a pas les élévations des habitations
on en droit de supposer qu'elle avait le
même type de couverture que celle
découverte en sibérie ces différents
exemples ont davantage de montrer la
volonté de bâtir d'organiser l'espace et
de créer des aires d'activités dans
l'habitation déjà au coeur des plus
anciennes images que nous avons de
l'homme préhistorique est une image
faussée si l'homme résidait dans une
grotte c'était pour des raisons liées à
la chasse à l'accueil est parfois la
protection mais ce de façon très
temporaire en france les hommes
préhistoriques se sont installés par
exemple dont la grande du lazaret à
proximité de nice en 150 milles avant
notre ère les vestiges nous montrent
qu'ils n'occupaient pas la totalité de
l'espace
et comme moyen de pierre il avait
délimité une zone domestique dans la
grotte
il ya donc une volonté de créer un
espace à part dans la grotte en
l'aménageant et en créant peut-être même
une intimité
la grotte à certains avantages les toits
et les murs sont déjà l'or et ça les
hommes préhistoriques savait pas s'en
priver
ils construisaient des maisons lorsqu'il
n'avait pas d'autres possibilités est
d'ailleurs une occuper la part du temps
pas des grottes mais des abris sous
roche qui permettent de garder un accès
à la lumière et de s'abriter des
intempéries
en tout cas après cette description on
comprend que bâtir sa maison son lieu de
vie intime familiale semble toujours
avoir été une priorité pour l'homme
et il ne faut pas représenter l'homme
paléolithique comme un troglodyte
primitif évidemment pour les parts des
plus anciennes les niveaux de
développement technique ont joué un rôle
majeur dans le choix des constructions
mais rappelons qu'à cette période on
avait et on prenait le temps d'apprendre
à construire et surtout en expérimenter
en permanence maintenant on va se
pencher sur des exemples de logements
beaucoup plus récent c'est à dire du
siècle dernier
et en passant par l'après-guerre et puis
on finira avec les maisons neuves dite
basse consommation écologique
l'idée que le confort est amélioré avec
les technologies et les matériaux
modernes et très présente dans nos
esprits on a aussi souvent en tête que
le matériau nouveau et de meilleure
qualité que le matériau dits
traditionnels
est ce qu'une maison construite avec les
méthodes des matériaux nouveaux et plus
confortable qu'une maison en paille en
terre ou hambourg qu'est ce que le béton
vaut mieux que la pierre ou la terre
rien n'est moins sûr car ce qui compte
au final dans une maison c'est qu'on s'y
sent bien
cependant la notion de confort est en
fait très variable selon les personnes
ou les sociétés ce qui ne nous aide pas
du tout à définir ce que serait qu'une
maison moderne comme pour la première
vidéo
la réflexion sur la modernité dans son
sens commun est en fait une réflexion
sur la qualité des choses produites par
l'homme aujourd'hui en traitant de la
maison nous devons aborder dans un
premier temps la question des matériaux
jusqu'à très récemment les maisons
étaient encore construites en terre
pierre et en bois donc les mêmes
matériaux dont disposent les hommes
préhistoriques l'exception du fer les
connaissances sur ces matériaux ont été
acquises très tôt et n'ont été que peu
modifié
en réalité on a toujours construit de
façon logique en utilisant les
ressources à disposition ce qui explique
les tendances architecturales de
certaines régions
l'ardoisé pour la bretagne la pierre
pour la lozère et massif central ou
encore la terre en rhône alpes
ce n'est qu'avec l'apparition de
nouvelles préparations team béton et
plastiques au xxème siècle que je m'en a
connu une grande transformation pour le
meilleur et pour le pire
tous ces matériaux issus de gisements
pierre terre bois fibres végétales ont
leurs avantages et leurs inconvénients
une maison en pierre par exemple n'a pas
besoin d'être entretenue par contre les
espaces sont très difficiles à chauffer
durant l'hiver une maison en terre comme
les maisons à colombages en pisé
présente d'excellentes aptitudes à
l'isolation thermique mais ont
l'inconvénient d'être friable cette
technique de construction sont d'une
grande complexité il faut faire
attention à la qualité du matériau au
temps de séchage à la ventilation au
saison est également haut degré de
militer pour qu'on soit de la sorte il
fallait du temps un savoir faire
technique et certains diront de la
passion depuis quelques temps ces
chantiers connaissent un regain
d'intérêt de la part de ceux qui sont
réfractaires au tout béton cette vidéo
serait donc incomplète si on n'évoquait
pas le cas du béton qui est toujours à
l'heure actuelle le match
le plus prisé dans la construction parce
que ce qui a remplacé la terre dans le
bâti c'est le béton justement pour des
questions de temps aidant non je
l'évoquais juste avant le 20e siècle est
marqué par l'utilisation en masse du
béton ciment aussi bien pour les
constructions publiques pour les
logements privés depuis l'après-guerre
nous avons construit vite pour régler
des problèmes de société à moindre coût
il a fallu concevoir des bâtiments pour
palais la croissance démographique et
l'exode rural ces bâtiments qui forment
pour la plupart nos banlieues et
lotissements encore aujourd'hui furent à
l'époque les emblèmes de la modernité
parce qu'ils avaient un impact visuel
économique et symbolique très fort en
effet il permettait de loger tout le
monde à bas prix tout en améliorant les
conditions de vie seulement à cette
époque on a pensé à court terme ou du
moins n'avait pas aux nécessaires sur le
béton et son entretien depuis quelques
décennies ces structures sont vivement
critiquées du fait de leur insalubrité
en un temps très court 50 ans le béton
se dégrader comme il s'agit souvent de
construction imposante les rénovations
sont trop coûteuses et conduisent donc
soit à l'abandon du projet soit
carrément à sa destruction
ça a été le cas à mantes la jolie en
septembre 1992
comme on peut le voir sur ces images ou
quatre tours du val fourré sur des
routes
c'était à l'époque pour la municipalité
un signe fort pour tourner la page et
annoncer de nouveaux projets on a donné
un bruit là c'était ben voilà mes
données a poussé la partie d'un nouveau
depuis 92 que s'est il passé quelles ont
été les positionnements du gouvernement
sylvette on est toujours prisé à l'heure
actuelle ces composants commence à 1 re
buts est certain d'une part l'extraction
du ciment est très énergivore et d'autre
part une maison en béton va de pair avec
une liste de matériaux polluants et
dangereux pour la santé à savoir laine
de verre polystyrène expansé acier
parpaings de nos jours construire plus
écologiques ou en tout cas dépenser
moins d'énergie est une véritable
préoccupation tout le monde cherche à
réduire sa consommation d'électricité et
de gaz de grandes campagnes
publicitaires sont lancés par les
groupes de l'énergie en france nous
sommes dans une période où il est
nécessaire de repenser notre manière de
se loger
peut-on espérer à défaut de vivre tels
des hommes préhistoriques dans un monde
sans plastique et pétrole réussir à
inventer la maison du futur c'est à dire
la maison qui correspondent mieux aux
enjeux de notre société
moins de pollution et toujours plus de
confort alors quelles solutions
s'offrent à nous depuis quelques années
il est question de deux types de maison
correspondant à des normes thermiques
bien précises les maisons dites basse
consommation et les maisons passives
sur le papier c'est très joli on crée un
espace totalement hermétique où on
contrôle toutes les entrées d'air
l'objectif affiché est zéro consommation
qui ce type de maison est écologique à
la consommation il ne l'est absolument
pas la construction les murs contiennent
des couches épaisses de plastique pour
atteindre un tel niveau d'isolation et
les fenêtres sont en pvc ou pire en
aluminium et les systèmes d'aération ne
sont pas aussi câble depuis 2012 année
de la publication de cette
réglementation thermique
l'état a donc fait un choix que l'on
peut résumer de la façon suivante pour
lui à la construction utilisé des
matériaux issus de la pétrochimie et
ensuite consommer le moins possible
où trouverait d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'informations sur le net car on parle
ici de technologies récentes et donc
tout un marché s'est ouvert
en clair aujourd'hui si vous voulez
construire 2009 vous êtes obligés de
suivre cette réglementation
c'est une idée de confort qui est la
même pour tous et à laquelle vous
v consentir
que faire si ce modèle de maison et de
vie ne correspond pas à vos attentes
pour trouver des alternatives à sa
notamment dans la construction
écologique qui utilise des matériaux
naturels et issus de ressources locales
ça a été beaucoup plus compliquée et
comme c'est difficile de se faire une
idée sur la construction écolo je suis
allé voir une amie architecte spécialisé
dans la construction en terre pour
discuter de tout ça avec elle
la première question fut pourquoi déjà
construire écologique
le but premier est de se tourner vers
des matériaux non polluants et non
agressif pour la santé construire écolo
peut être un choix économique
en effet quand on emploie des matériaux
venant de ressources locales c'est plus
économique que de faire venir les
matériaux mais ce peut être également un
choix esthétique le matériau employé
donne déjà une idée des formes et de
l'aspect du bâtiment finale je demande
alors qu'est ce qu'une maison écolo la
réponse et il n'y a pas de maison 100%
écologique et on ne peut pas être 100%
écologique mais on peut s'en rapprocher
ce qui s'en rapprocherait plus
d'ailleurs ce serait la grotte tiens on
y revient ou une cabane de bois mort
dans la forêt en somme quelque chose qui
lorsqu'on l'abandonnent ne laisse aucun
déchet on associe souvent et à raison
écologie et durabilité
en effet la notion de temps est
primordiale lorsque l'on construit en
combien de temps construites ont une
maison
cette question peut sembler évident car
tout le monde souhaite que sa maison
reste debout le plus longtemps possible
pourtant en pratique on l'a vu avec
l'exemple des banlieues ces projets
colossaux ont été détruits quarante ans
après leur construction
quarante ans c'est court nous surtout à
notre époque avec les matériaux à
disposition et les technologies modernes
à titre de comparaison il ya des maisons
en paille dans le bassin parisien qui on
s'entend
le point à retenir les suivants maison
peut être écologique à la construction
mais pas forcément à la consommation
sept cas de la maison en pierres qu'on
est vous qui est un peu avant au
contraire une maison en bois bénéficiant
de panneaux solaires sera écologique car
dit parce consommation qu'adviendra-t-il
des panneaux solaires le jour où il
faudra les remplacer on ne sait pas les
recycler et le bois qui est utilisé pour
de telles constructions est importé en
camion dernier exemple c'est celui des
toitures végétales qui sont très en
vogue actuellement mais qui ne sont
absolument pas écologique
elles peuvent l'être mais
seulement avec des techniques anciennes
et dans certaines régions bénéficiant de
réserve en tout comme en allemagne et en
scandinavie
en france les tourbières sont assez
rares donc cette matière organique
fossiles est remplacée par une bâche
plastique
ces initiatives sont pourtant bonne et
il faut pas entendre mon discours que
pessimiste mais simplement savoir de
quoi on parle des défauts de chaque
matériau et des possibilités qu'il offre
il s'agit d'un compromis construire
écolo se situerait alors dans l'alliance
des techniques modernes et de la logique
et du bon sens des siècles passés
mon ami disait que la maison la plus
écologique était la grotte préhistorique
ou la cabane en bois
c'est impensable ce que j'ai de la sorte
aujourd'hui et ce n'est pas le but mais
ça fait réfléchir lorsque l'on voit les
conditions dans lesquelles vivent de
plus en plus de personnes on empile on
cloisonne on paie une sortie d'un 17
mètres carrés mais on vous promet la
fibre pour maintenir du lien social
la répartition des maisons et la
traduction spatiale des rapports sociaux
dominants rapport de castres rapports de
parenté rapports de classe l'habitation
par sa superficie et son apparence est
un signe du statut socioéconomique de
ceux qui résident la maison ou
l'appartement occidentale que nous avons
érigé comme modèle n'est pas forcément
le logement idéal au regard d'autres
sociétés selon les sociétés la vision
idéale du confort peut être la recherche
de l'ombre ou de la lumière du frais ou
du tiède de la distance ou de la
proximité entre les individus et ça
c'est valable à toutes les époques de
l'humanité on arrive au terme de cette
vidéo que peut-on retenir
comment faire le lien entre les exemples
de la préhistoire et ceux d'aujourd'hui
sur la question de la modernité
eh bien ces différents exemples qu'il
soit très anciens ou très récent nous
montre une fois encore que la définition
de la modernité est très complexe et
qu'elle ne dépend finalement ni du
niveau d'intelligence des hommes ni de
leur richesse matérielle un bâtiment un
logement est une réussite s'il permet à
ceux qui résident d'améliorer leurs
conditions de vie ou du moins de
répondre à leurs besoins qu'il s'agisse
d'un abri sous roche pour les hommes
préhistoriques ou d'une nouvelle laverie
dans le hall d'un immeuble
les exemples archéologiques nous montre
que les hommes préhistoriques envisager
l'or
vie de façon globale il ne construisait
pas seulement une hutte dans un coin il
pensait également à ce qui se trouvaient
autour de la maison comme par exemple
des ateliers de taille de silex de
confection dépôts et de stockage de la
nourriture
même s'il n'en avait pas conscience il
avait déjà fait de l'habitat un objet de
civilisation et c'est bien cette notion
de globalité de concevoir sa maison en
pensant à ce qui se trouve au taux qui
est une démarche que l'on peut qualifier
de moderne pour les projets récents bien
souvent seules les questions de
rentabilité et d'uniformisation on
comptait bien sûr il a eu des exceptions
à l'image de la cité radieuse de
firminy-vert en loire élaboré par le
corbusier en 54 où l'on envisageait la
ville moderne comme une ville verte est
en lien avec le centre ville historique
ce projet avait pour but premier
d'offrir une qualité de vie supérieure
aux habitants en leur fournissant pour
la première fois des salles de bain des
laveries des garderies dans les
immeubles
il a perduré un temps règle en partie
les problèmes de la ville mais fut très
difficile à maintenir sur le long terme
la notion de confort ne suffit pas à
évaluer le niveau de modernité d'une
maison la modernité airs et
interprétable elle varie on a pu
considérer que la maison moderne était
un idéal de technologie mais cette
perspective a été en partie renversé par
les attentes écologiques
l'idée de modernité et donc arbitraire
si la modernité est un idéal de réussite
alors être moderne serait plutôt
apprendre de ses erreurs et la synthèse
entre le confort et le respect de
l'environnement est sans doute encore
inventé nous devant nous notre tort être
suffisamment claire de notre époque qui
auront bien d'autres ou non seulement
nous bâtissons pour la pérennité même
nous bâtissons aussi pour que les hommes
vivent mieux dans leurs cellules
primitives dans la famille afin que le
foyer soit abriter vraiment c'est la
volonté des hommes de notre temps de ne
pas accepter d'être enfermé toute la vie
dans une muraille de pierre et pour cela
il faut dénoncer les faux semblants où
les demies solution est un moment toulon
rebâti avec économie avec parcimonie
peut-être il ne faut pas oublier
et que tout peut être magnifiée par
l'esprit alors que touriste terai d'être
mutilée par l'argent